everyone it's me Gary um so I want to
make this video there's a classic kind
of video in my world where I cold call
advertisers and sell them advertising
for my fake beer show and some quite
well and a lot of you have seen that and
thanks for that can we link that in the
youtube thing cool but today I want to
make a point about how you can do the
same exact thing but the context of the
situation and the way you go about it
changes the game in media everybody's
pushing out commercials and pre-rolls
and this that and the other thing and I
keep telling them what social does is
allows all of us to act much more human
so i titled this video sent flowers in
July twelfth guys who are watching us
you know that when you get your you know
wife your girlfriend your mistress you
know whoever however you roll when you
get them flowers on Valentine's Day you
know that's expected and so you get some
points but you don't get the points that
I'm about to get so this video is fun
for me I'm sending my wife Lizzie some
flowers in a second I did this in a new
wave way so like put up this screenshot
I tweet it out which flower shop is a
best in New York and kind of an essence
wants my business kudos to H bloom they
just gave me a thing just to help they
just gave me their number so I gotta
climb we'll see how there are services
and right now I'm gonna buy my wife
flowers and I'm going to send it to her
and she's going to be much happier by
getting them today randomly I'm thinking
about her giving the extra effort and
this is what I want people to do with
media I want them to engage and do
different things and actually bring
value to the situation this is where a
lot of people get very confused we're
trying to push out our message over and
over a pre-roll a banner a honeymoon hey
H bloom this is gary vaynerchuk I was
just on Twitter and was asked to call
this number yeah we thaw awesome how are
you okay what can we help you um grande
what can we help you with today I'd like
to send my way some flowers okay and
what did you have in mind something
special something special um can you
home
Nathan cry yes mate knows the rules make
what can I do I'm on fragrance on
fragrance because it a little bit later
in the day I'm gonna have to see and got
on hands probably gonna need orchid with
that work for you yeah that's beautiful
orchids are gorgeous let's do that thing
goes my orchid amazed perfect have you
ordered with us before I think maybe but
I'm not sure how can we double check
when you look you all night um it's
happening it's vay any are CH UK maybe
not I definitely I feel it for bigger
media has right maybe I feel like it's
something okay let me hook you up on way
Kerry think you can you hear me awesome
so while this is happening the key
really hear any I want no worries the
key is I'm gonna get so much more value
for this impression right when this
actual same thing that will happen on
februari 14th or am a six on her
birthday this same exact maneuver the
same exact thing the reason this is
going to get me much more points at home
and the same way that you can do by
surprising something sending them
surprise in what can I like that it's a
gary g ary at Vayner vay ner dia calm
okay
feel free to email sorry keep got a
phone no worries so the key here is this
event is the same as it would happen in
other times but disguising propelled you
put in a new account for you see no no
works too long no we're stuck period at
vaynermedia calm yep okay wonderful so
we're going to do a single stem white
orchid yep okay and what's the address
is going to
ok and what you wake me Lizzie li z zi e
and I really I eat yep looking last name
yep by God I already and you have a
phone number for her or for you that we
can that I up delivery person can use of
the contest okay would you like to
include a gift message yes I love you
with all my heart
do you want to end that with a yep my
shook up knowing okay with up lied yup I
love you with all my heart boo-boo bear
and keep it real is that love boo boo
bear yeah let's love boo boo bear okay
in that one word if you were a boo boo
bear that's too much eva peppers ok this
is dying I was blinking on it wonderful
can you hold on one second hand can you
/ secularly absolutely so here's the
gist a brand jumps on Twitter gets the
business gets all the impressions of
this now everybody knows about @h bloom
give them gaps number two I get points
from doing something of a surprise the
impression and the engagement and the
cost is the same but the emotional high
is much greater start thinking about how
surprising your customers your employees
when it's not expected that extra effort
effort is the gross underestimated
aspect of everything that's going on in
the world do the same exact thing with a
little applied effort and you get much
more upside send the flowers on july 12